Mark Anthony and Nadia Ferreira
officially say I do is just the
beginning E.T confirms the singer
married the Miss Universe contestant in
Miami on Saturday and it was a
star-studded affair the guest list
included celebs like Leah Remini Salma
Hayek and Daddy Yankee
plus David and Victoria Beckham were in
attendance with David as Mark's best man
but our source tells us notably missing
at the celebration marks kids with ex
Jennifer Lopez Max and Emmy
et's Insider adds that the couple's 250
guests arrived at 7 pm for the ceremony
and most left around 4 a.m just have fun
check out Mark looking Dapper at the
Perez art museum in Miami where the two
tied the knot a source tells ET that
when Nadia walked down the aisle Mark
was emotional and even teared up
absolutely after the nuptials a cocktail
hour took place in a tent decorated in
all white roses DJ Cassidy who's
performed at Jay-Z and Beyonce's wedding
kept the crowd dancing this is just a
blessing our source adds that Nadia and
Mark looked like they were on cloud nine
neither of them stopped smiling
throughout the night going on to say
that everyone attending the fairy tale
wedding could feel the love between the
two never never never stop
uh feeling that you're lucky the pairs
lavish Miami ceremony comes after Mark
proposed in May last year at the time
Nadia shared the happy news on Instagram
showing off her engagement ring fast
forward eight months later they're
officially hitched and happier than ever
congrats to the newlyweds
[Music]